is a stranger for fine thank you  I am the envy of a lot of my friends  that I've kissed both Franco brothers  you might be the only person on earth  you think yak Emma made out with James  in Palo Alto and now Dave and nerve so  first question which Franco brother he's  the better kisser the stars were bold  enough to strip down to their underwear  the amount of conversations that were  had about what my Ron underwear would  look like it would got to a point of  like ridiculousness so I was like okay  guys I'm just gonna pick brought  underwear and we're gonna call it a day  what are they bold enough for our dare  you look back at the footage I gotta get  you're like give me it  Joe are you sure don't give it back  you